florida's desantis has signed the
parental rights and education bill hits
back at hollywood critics democrats
misleadingly attacked florida
legislation as don't say gay bill i like
that at fox news subhead accurately
points out that they've been lying the
whole time about what this bill does now
my understanding is the initial
inception of it was more so targeting
you know don't teach about gender
identity or whatever after several
amendments they came to okay how about
we just say
pre-k you know preschool to third grade
we don't want you teaching
identity and orientation stuff to
children to these nine to four four to
nine year olds after that it's fine just
keep it age-appropriate and for those
four-year-olds as long as you talk to
them in a semi-private setting totally
okay did you know that
if in florida
this bill that was passed by republicans
will still allow a teacher to go up to a
four-year-old in a semi-private setting
meaning if there's if they're in a
classroom there's a bunch of kids
running around they're playing a teacher
can get up and walk over to a group of
kids and say do you want to learn about
being trans oh my god the bill does not
ban that okay and so that's what they've
been they've been claiming maybe we'll
make some calls into the florida
legislature yeah i mean it does again we
were talking about it being an
anti-grooming bill but it doesn't go
nearly far enough to even be called that
yeah it's it i call it the don't say
straight bill yeah because the teachers
also can't talk to these kids about
straight traditional marriage so i'm
gonna be asked the biggest pet peeve i
have with this whole outrage is that
when i was in high school just like six
years ago if i said gay in any situation
i get detention like alex you can't say
gay
and i tweet gay and now you know
congressmen who hate me they they find
screenshots of my tweets when i was 14
and i say the word gay in it he's a
homophobe
so you used to get in trouble if you
said the word gay and now you see these
idiots running through the halls of the
school yelling gay and get no pink slips
no detention that's the bone i got to
pick with this bill primarily
um
it's just i grew up in the wrong times
have you seen the meme where it's all
the disney work all the stories about
disney workers being arrested for child
exploitation oh absolutely that's
there's a great sheriff in that region
of florida named uh uh gary jud sheriff
judd he's phenomenal and i think he
busted like 17 disney workers for
like uh pedophile pedophilia and
trafficking kids it's a sick i mean and
also disney's so outraged about banning
sex ed from
young kids like this
i can guarantee when i have children
they will never watch disney what kind
of subliminal messaging and and crap do
they put in there whoa whoa you don't
know the urban legends about disney and
their subliminal sex oh yeah have you
seen that clip from the lion king oh
yeah which one is that one all good
girls take off their clothes oh um that
was aladdin so
right now
when simba falls down onto the the um
flowers the pollen flies up into the air
and it spells the word sex and disney
claimed no no no no it said sfx we were
excited about our new sound effects
package i'm not kidding what the hell
they said
you know it's mental it's a mental
illness that they want to teach their
kids these kids about sex and they need
to be held accountable for and i think
desantis should reconsider the bill and
make it even tougher out of this
backlash
and also consider revoking some teaching
license from these these teachers who
are so uh enraged by it and who wants to
push their sexuality on these kids yeah
perverts yeah
sick perverts and the only people who
won't stand up against this are the
really sick perverts or they're complete
cowards because the responsibility of
adults is to protect children and as it
happens we live in a culture where
people are so fundamentally either
depraved or terrified and completely
weak that they would rather allow
children to be groomed than be called
homophobic or some other word that
everyone's too terrified to be labeled
with to actually stand up and protect
children against disgusting predators
this one might be
just you know people
wishful thinking i don't know about
wishful thinking but like
looking for something and then telling
everyone it's true yeah so but let's see
what snopes has to say about this disney
thing right
was a phallus purposefully added to the
artwork of the little mermaid from 1998
false
and you can see
it's just a golden tower of various you
know sizes and then uh what do we have
it here where did it go there you go
it's just
it's just a golden castle palace tower
and everybody i know would always point
this out and be like hey look what they
put on the cover
you also have um
what was it it was aladdin right uh when
when he was talking to uh uh
aladdin was talking to jasmine do you
know this one it sounds like yeah i i
remember the clip
and then also in the rescuers there was
an example i can't remember if it was
the rescuers or the rescuers down under
but as they fly uh past the series of
buildings there's actually a
pornographic image that's placed inside
one of the windows that's on camera for
a fraction of a second but it is there
here's snopes again did aladdin ask
teenagers take off their clothes
false oh it's false
good teenagers take off your clothes
in the lad and he whispers it
so let's see can we play it are we going
to get youtube down
[Music]
what was that they didn't even play it
i don't know man like trust disney maybe
maybe the lion king one is like they
really wanted to say sfx but uh
like
maybe
why even have it say anything right i
know
but but so anyway i bring up the disney
thing because it makes sense if like
these predators want to go to the to
these disney parks where there's kids
everywhere they're getting caught
what's fascinating to me is
maybe it's just coincidence that florida
says hey we don't want you talking to
kids about this stuff whether it's
straight or gay or otherwise
and then they're like oh oh harumph i
say how dare do you tell us we can't say
gay and they go around running through
the hallways and then it's like also
there's a ton of predators down there at
disney you know it's like they had a
coincidence no yeah well i mean we
talked about this uh a few shows ago but
brian peck was
hired to be a consultant on a disney
film after or on a disney project after
being found guilty of sexually abusing a
child oh man yeah there's some really
demented people out there and um
the outrage this bill and i'm glad that
you brought that point up how it doesn't
go far enough and if i know anything
about rhonda santos he's going to want
to make sure it's even tougher and he's
not he's not going to cower to this
outrage he's going to in fact probably
double down but but maybe
i mean the challenge is republicans are
consistently reasonable the democrats
accuse them of being vicious
authoritarians and look what they're
they do they're like you can still teach
kids about the stuff just not as a
classroom discussion
and and you know
it's it's like why are you giving leeway
there's no room to negotiate on this one
these are children yes uh they shouldn't
even be able to have these they
shouldn't even be allowed to have a
conversation period because this this
whole idea that you can change your
agenda that should not be a conversation
that we ever normalize nor accept and so
the idea that some unqualified teacher
who's a creep is going to have this
conversation with your child you can't
let that happen and so but uh we can't
be reasonable no leeway on this i keep
hearing from from parents who say i
can't speak up because i'd lose my job
and i'm just kind of like
it's kind of scary it's a kind of scary
it's kind of a scary prospect that uh
you're more concerned about your job
than who your kid is around for eight
hours every day absolutely there's
another job out there and you know you
don't have that many kids maybe you do
imagine imagine being willing to work
for the kind of employer who would fire
you because you are against sexual
perverts trying to groom your child and
you're vocal about that yeah
i think people need to hear you can
succeed i think people need to hear that
they're they're you you said there are
other jobs out there there was what's
that website for like anti-woke people
square something is that what it was i
don't know company square or something
yeah square's a payment processing
company square is a payment
but there's another yeah there's another
website you go to and it's like job
listings for people who aren't woke oh
yeah well god bless them we you got to
find that out and get to promote the
hell out of them i'm going to promote
them uh i mean
people need to have the courage to you
know stand up and say this stuff's
enough well people yeah i remember fire
and and look i was in high school when
when uh gay marriage was legalized or
you know the supreme court ruling and i
used to i used to be like what's even
the
fight about gay marriage like you know
the conservatives on their talk radio
would be like well if we normalize this
what else are we forced to normalize i'm
like oh they're just bigots or whatever
and then five years later six years
later uh somebody who was a woman for
four days gets named uh sports
illustrated woman of the year caitlyn
jenner and now we're in this next phase
of the the the transition into
normalizing stuff but the grooming crap
it's because there's there's no end
right they say the ends justify the
means but there is no end meaning no
matter where you are you're always
moving in one direction the issue is for
me it's not
it's it's it's not gay marriage or
slippery slope fallacy i think two
consenting adults is not the issue
obviously there's a lot of traditional
conservatives have issue with that i
disagree the issue is children
who can't consent that's always been the
point adults can consent because they're
they're you know they can go and do
their thing children cannot
it's i look at this like
there needs to be a hard line you you i
i don't need to come on be like what's
next you know dogs and cats you know
living together or whatever no no i just
be like yo i don't care about consenting
adults i care about this hard line stop
done have a nice day yeah you know
who's phenomenal on this it's an open
secret that that twitter account i think
is open and i've gotten to know the
folks behind that pretty well and they
say we gotta stop talk using the term
child porn because porn's a consenting
term and children can't consent it's her
child it's child rape and torture
material uh and so i i try not to use
the term child porn uh in my rhetoric
because you can't when you're a child
you can't consent um and and children
can never consent we can never normalize
that and so we have to you're right you
do have to stand up for the kids um and
the parents need to wake the hell up uh
and and and they need to be vocal they
need to be the ones that stop this yeah
i i want to make another point here
piggybacking off of what you just said
about all the arguments that were made
by conservatives about gay marriage just
a few years ago and where we are in
relation to those
it's not just the case that basically
every prediction made by the christian
right about what would happen in america
after gay rights were legalized and gay
rights were normalized happened it's
that like the most cartoonish
strawmanned version of their argument
that a left winger would have come up
with 10 years ago has turned out to be
what's actually child drag yes exactly
like child drag shows and also uh left
like pink news thinking that it is bad
press for the republican party for them
to go out there and go did you know that
the republicans are going to try to ban
child drag shows if they get elected
and expecting people to look at that and
go oh wow well i'd better not vote
and look i i still believe that i'm i'm
okay with gay marriage personally okay
whatever um but but
the the stuff that's come from after it
it it's been it's been messed up the the
trans rights has been such a fa you know
weird issue and and i think dave
chappelle uh kind of lays it out nicely
and he's like you guys need to disown
these other people you need to
discipline the team
this is the problem this is the problem
there are people like i think caitlyn
jenner has been great speaking up in
defense of uh women's sports people like
blair white i think are fantastic there
is a scientist a science researcher a
trans woman who's talked about male
advantages in sports i think you know
look people want to live their lives the
way they want to live i'm very civil
libertarian libertarian the issue is
there are there are bad people who are
trying to cover up their their their
what they're doing by hiding within the
lgbt community and the challenge is when
you call out these bad people
they will use that and that and say
obviously you're attacking trans people
no no that that is a person preying on
on little girls going into the girls
bath and taking pictures of them yeah i
i got no issue with the trans person i
got an issue with with the people
exploiting it
but you'll get banned yeah and you'll
get kicked off but i'm glad that people
like blair and
are are speaking out against this you
know this crap and we need more
hopefully well more like them if there
are them um but
well there's just one more thing i want
to say here because i i i hear what you
guys are saying i don't think we share a
perspective here particularly on gay
marriage i think once a society says
that two men can be married and tries to
redefine marriage in that way we've
already lost the plot on what gender
roles are and so we're open to any uh
and everything happening with the
relationship between men and women that
doesn't really correspond to reality and
what the the sexes do and how they're
designed to relate to one another that's
a long philosophical moral philosophy
ethical conversation i think it's a
libertarian like right now we're saying
like libertarian versus conservative
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there
you